well hello and welcome to another
adventure me and Nate here we're gonna
go do some exploration this is kind of a
fun trip because we're going to the
place we've never been before and we
don't know how long we're gonna be gone
I have the next three days off and so I
am just gonna go and we'll come back
whenever we feel like it ready for an
adventure Nathan let's go well we have
about 15 or 20 rods with us and a nice
little boat so we are ready for just
about anything it's gonna be fun buddy
alright we're here at green top we're
gonna pick up some bait and a few odds
and ends and probably spend more money
than we anticipated but it's an
important part of the fishing process
gonna write that hop on in bud
there you go earthworm take I got a
bunch of these these little foam poppers
and stuff
I think these we've made awesome zig-rig
so I'm gonna buy a bunch of these and
try them out a zig rigs for carving well
I came in here to buy some earthworms
instead I spent five hundred and forty
dollars on fly fishing gear
she'd just dig my own babe
[Music]
you have a right
well I've only been on this river one
time and I've never been on this part of
the river but this waters kind of big
for my taste so I think we should go
upstream a little bit and see what we
can find
well I'm sitting about 20 feet of water
I'm taking a look at the sonar here and
seeing lots of signals so I think we
might throw the casting that out and
start getting ourselves some bait well I
threw the net three times and I come up
with nothing I think it's because I'm
using the wrong type of net I saw some
fish jumping right here so we're gonna
go ahead and try the cast net again
photographer Nate you ready
[Music]
well I throw in the net like a dozen
times I'm seeing little fish everywhere
but I'm not catching I think what
happened is the fish are up at the water
column and my net has very fine mesh so
it's not catching the fish in their
gills
instead the net goes in like this it
sinks to the bottom and the fish are
swimming out before it gets to the
bottom because we're like thirty feet of
water so there's a lot of time for those
fish to escape I think that's what's
happening well plan B is them take some
earthworms and some of these little
doctor demon rods and we're gonna see if
we can't catch some blue yo all right
we're just sitting here drifting some
worms along the bottom seeing if we
can't pick up some white perch or
bluegill or anything and we've got one
hit but not much I mean we need to be
catching fish pretty quick if we're
gonna get bait before sunset and get
situated so feeling a little pressured
here finally finally you've got into
some of these little white perch they're
not huge but I'm glad to see them
[Music]
it's Wendy Meadows but you gotta finish
right here
oh he just he just grabbed that pulled
that way over and let it go oh he's
moving he's got little teeth marks on
him well I've got a couple bites but not
really the action we're looking for so
we're gonna pull up anchor and go try
somewhere else before the Sun sets on us
all right we're gonna try just dragging
some baits across the bottom and see
what happens there's a fishery here you
want to reel them in yeah yeah I got the
light I got the light he popped right
off whoop I felt that that got bit so
hard it made it tip the boat over boy
landed one catfish got a few bites here
and there the Sun set give us a little
bit more it's past Nate's bedtime but
we're kind of letting him stay up a
little bit oh oh oh a little tiny
catfish oh there's another one
there you go bud nice blue catfish
all right we're throwback hey there you
well things are starting to heat up but
I can see lightning over there so we got
to get off the water it is way too late
to get home tonight and so I think we're
gonna go ahead and get a hotel and then
maybe go fishing a little bit more
tomorrow what do you think need is this
been a fun trip
all right we got ourselves a little
hotel room we crash for the night see
about ordering some pizza
oh there you there you go buddy get your
very own bed this is all use this pretty
dice there you go little boy eat this
pizza bed that's living the life I will
see you guys in the morning what is this
we get we're watching PJ masks at
breakfast this is the best hotel ever
excellent both still here nobody stole
my fish finder that's nice this way
[Music]
yes
[Music]
whoever alright did much better on this
trip to a bait shop all right got a big
frozen gizzard shad some earthworms and
some extra bobbers here comes the rain
buddy a little rain storm ain't a bad
thing that boat really needs a wash
though jello panko bread crumbs one got
my poncho bait made up let's go get some
carp well this is a beautiful Lake I'm
anxious to explore this you ready to do
this Nathan
well this lake is supposed to have some
big carp in it it's also supposed to be
a very snaggy place to fish so we're
gonna check this out and see what
happens
these cypress trees never get all
they're so beautiful this is just
gorgeous I think we go ahead and drop
some bait over there and see what
happens
all right we're gonna take a nice big
blob flavoring there we go
most Lakes either have large quantities
of carp or they have very large carp but
not both this is supposed to be a trophy
carp lake so I'm not expecting a lot of
numbers it may take a little while to
get a bite so I'm gonna sit here a
little bit longer than I normally would
and while I'm at it I'm also going to
throw out some catfish rates and I've
got myself a big frozen gizzard shad so
I'm gonna chop this bad boy up and get
some worms and other things and check it
off the front of okay let's just see
what happens we have a ton of rods out
we're gonna find out if there's any
catfish or carp in this area this has
got cut shad cut shad punko punko cut
shad punko punko punko cut shad so if my
math serves me correctly we have four
for catfish rods in one two three four
five carp rods we have nine rods out if
we can't hook something there ain't no
fish here
hey Nathan what you fishing with got a
whisker stick what kind of bait you got
on cut up [ __ ]
[Music]
they didn't try that you like that call
the fried pie well we've been here about
an hour and haven't gotten a single
nibble or bite so I think we're gonna
pull up and try another spot
you know we're exploring
my pants were getting pretty wet so
we're gonna fish here for a little bit
but there's some actual decent signals
on the fishfinder so this might actually
be a good spot look it's really starting
to rain i'm glad we're not out there
loud kids scared away fish I'd never
catch a fish oh look at Oh God
that's a nice bream here come over here
to me
look at that that's it that's a big
shell cracker I think already err very
nice ready or buddy swallow that hook
terribly let's just blood out the gills
so we're gonna go ahead and keep him but
he's such a nice fish I don't want to
use them for bait I kind of think we
should eat them man look at the size of
that guy it's just a plain old bluegill
there you go there you go bluegill well
the rain seems to have stops we're gonna
pull a banker and score the lake a
little bit more
[Music]
yeah there we go we're anchored up
you're trying to stick and move this is
a really nice trick beating yourself on
a log like this is a real quick way to
anchor up and all that doesn't disturb
the fish as much my splashing anchors
and it works really good with high wind
[Music]
blew Gill got our two little red ears
and a bluegill Oh one horrible blow job
mostly skin but there we go
horrible horrible filets a lot of pan
fish here but nothing on the carp rods I
think we're gonna pull it up and go home
because we got a long drive and I've got
some fish to cook up when I get home
one day 'then are you not wet enough you
wet your pants all we had a good time
didn't we need ya but we're very wet so
let's go home and see mama in a quarter
of a mile to get out we got some
flooding going on here
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a car over there they hit it
deep spots up to its headlights and
water jeez we're going through
all right Nate we made it we're home how
much pee is inside your rain suit all
right let's go inside see mama is it
good to be home
do they have a bath all right very cook
up these little fillets here as I look
at these fillets I realize that I have
the knife skills of a seasoned to catch
and release fishing
[Music]
there you go nothing fancy just some
blackened red ear and bluegill prying up
these little scales on these fish it
kind of makes it have a little
crunchiness kind of like the consistency
of pork rinds or a Cheeto or something
actually quite good well I'm exhausted
so I'm gonna put the camera down and I
will see you guys tomorrow
we are on a beautiful River and I have
never fished this area before so we're
excited to go try this out I've got Nate
somewhere in the car in there well I'm
getting the boat launch
Nathan's down here and he got his own
rod out baited it himself and casted it
himself are you buddy you're becoming
quite the fisherman this is probably the
swiftest river I've ever taken his boat
on and there's lots of snags and rocks
to hit so I'm really trying to be
cautious
remember if we don't know what we're
doing do it slowly so we're gonna take
it easy
[Music]
I just saw a really big carp jump about
two feet out of the water right over
here in this area I'm gonna try to drop
an anchor right here and put the boat
right there and then fish down into that
shade I've got some of this punko pack
bait mixed with birdseed some plum
boilie extract some leftover jello I
kind of just took everything I had and
mixed it all together in a panco pack
bait well this is a beautiful spot but
it has not impressed me not even a pan
fish so we're gonna pull up anchor and
go try somewhere else well I just
clipped my first rock no damage done not
a big deal but it's ominous no I don't
know how much further we're gonna go
and I nailed that rock well hit some
rocks kill the engine and being the prop
a little bit I think we'll be okay well
we need to get some bait if we want to
do any catfish II and I'd like to sample
this river a little bit see what's down
here so I am going to use the cast net a
little bit
[Music]
that little cove looks nice all right
you got the carp rods out got a couple
catfish rods with worms on it and you
got a couple live minnows we had a
little bit of everything here a few
minutes not much has happened so I think
we might go home I've always been kind
of interested to see what this body of
water was like but I'm not not too
impressed well there we go that just
does exploring some new water we're
really trying to explore new waters this
year and and it's hit miss sometimes but
hey thanks for watching if you want to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
click Subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click Subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]